Teresa may insist the general election
is a straight choice between her and
Jeremy Corbyn but it's not that
clear-cut for all Gina Miller the
businesswoman who took the government to
the Supreme Court over its brexit plans
today launched best for Britain a
crowdfunded tactical voting campaign to
boost the chances of candidates pushing
for a real final vote on the brexit deal
the idea that Parliament should simply
rubber stamp a binary Deal or No Deal
option put by a future government and
ignore any other alternatives would
reduce democracy to a mere footnote
throughout the course of this general
election campaign we will be focusing on
educating and empowering people to make
a tactical vote and choosing MPs who
will do the best for Britain thanks to
the generous donations that we've
received we will be able to directly
support parliamentary candidates who are
committing committed to keeping all
options open
Gina Miller joins me now so you've
raised more than three hundred thousand
pounds already how many individuals is
that getting close to eleven thousand
people now which is extraordinary since
as it shows it's not just supporting the
idea but they're actually putting their
hands in their pocket so it's it you
know we couldn't be more delighted
you've catched donations at 500 pounds a
person that's that's the compliance it's
you know because we've enrolled with the
Electoral Commission that's just a
regulation that we have to abide by
beyond that people can give but there's
quite a lot of due diligence to do
looking at your board members Oh genome
and there are a lot of city types people
like Live carry that you've got the
chairman of virgin group you've got
private equity bosses a lot of people
say hang on these people really that
reflective of the UK populace look they
are they're concerned citizens like
anybody else but the board and the
organisation will cover the overheads
the money we're raising the crowdfunding
money will go directly every single
penny will go towards this best for
Britain campaign which if you like is a
contained campaign away from the bigger
organization so what are the
characteristics of the candidates that
you'll be supporting well it's too early
to tell we've only had a week but quite
a lot of other people who are in our
space are looking at what happened in
2015 and what have
in the referendum we're not we're saying
we need to know what's going on now how
people are feeling now on the ground so
we've commissioned polling data and
other online data we're using a number
of different methods and we're hoping
that next week with the overlay of all
the information we have will have be
able to identify those candidates that
we can work with but it's the strategy
going to be to support Pro remain
candidates or people who in favor of a
soft brexit or is it going to be
targeting Pro levers and trying to
decapitate them no it's much more
sophisticated than that because part of
our campaign is also to educate people
about the idea that people need to MPs
or candidates need to stand by their
principles and that's our number one
criteria is strong principled candidates
who will stand up and hold the
government to account and demand a final
vote whatever it is they voted for and
whatever their policies so we're trying
to be completely fair across both
political parties and disciplines
because of the open Britain organization
which was previously a cross-party body
a lot of the Conservatives who were
involved with that have now walked away
because they fear that the Tories are
going to be targeted by open written
there I think there's so many people in
this space that was their tactic we have
a very focused way of doing this and
we're not going to be saying it's one
party or another but the other question
of course is whether the candidates will
accept our money and if they're allowed
to so there are many ways we can work
with candidates but even if somebody
decided not to accept our money we can
still do a huge amount online to raise
people's awareness but you will be
trying to essentially get rid of the
likes of you and Duncan Smith Theresa
Villiers Kate Hoey these very very
staunchly pro-life MPs
presumably the question on the table is
and the brand is what is best for
Britain if an MP doesn't want to debate
that and is basically going to be a
rubber stamp but in our view that's
actually not serving their constituents
or their constituents and doing what's
best for Britain because common sense
says it has to be all options on the
table when the deal comes back because
brexit is going to dominate this
election and logic says all deals must
be on the table how can you not debate
that a lot of people say why don't you
just stand for Parliament yourself yes
I've had a few rumours a rumor mill has
been working overtime
Levi can do so much more outside of
Parliament also I have my day job and so
many other things to do